bonjour et bienvenue dans point de vue
est la une ce soir trois candidats est
un favori à la présidence de l air
laurent wauquiez déjà en campagne avec
une question fait-il de la surenchère
à droite on parlera également de cette
campagne un petit sucre pour papy ou
pour mamie c'est une proposition elle
est indécente de l'argent contre des
faveurs à une personne plus âgée c'est
ce que propose un site internet à des
étudiants et étudiantes faucher plaintes
en cascade
mais la justice est impuissante faut-il
détruire la croix de ploërmel
elle surplombe une statue de jean paul
ii elle indigne les libres penseurs et
le conseil d'état qui sommes la commune
bretonne de la supprimer
dans les six prochains mois en iran fin
à washington pas sûr qu'on en sache un
peu plus sur l'assassinât de kennedy
nous on sera peut-être un peu plus dans
le match ou plutôt dans bras de fer qui
oppose donald trump à la cia
on posera en tout cas la question à nos
invités et en particulier à la nouvelle
venue carole barjon bonjour bien le jour
on est heureux de vous avoir
vous êtes rédactrice en chef à l'ops
avec en une cette semaine la sélection à
l'université la fin d'un tabou chose
promise chose due un sondage annoncé ici
même par sylvain courage de semaine
dernière
65% des français sont favorables à la
sélection à l'université à noter que
vous êtes également lui l'auteur de mai
qui sont les assassins de l'école
sûrement pas olivier deuxième aile
président de la fondation nationale et
le cirage politique transition réussie
et auteur d'un livre réussit aussi dans
lequel on puisera d'ailleurs une partie
du débat ce soir macro et en même temps
c'est aux éditions plon
on reviendra aussi sur un autre livre
qu'elle ref réformer
quel discours pour convaincre il est
écrit par un historien
christophe de voogd qui spécialiste de
la rhétorique de rhétorique et d'idées
politiques qui êtes également prof à
sciences po m'entends avec nous enfin
alexis brézet directeur des rédactions
du figaro
bonsoir alexis on va parler de tous les
thèmes qu'on a évoqué mais on va d'abord
aller à barcelone carles s puis je
demande que le président de la
généralité de catalogne vient de
s'exprimer
il vient d'annoncer deux choses ou bien
lui vient de refuser d'en lancer
d'autres choses il refuse de convoquer
des éditions des élections anticipées
c'est ce que demandait le président du
gouvernement espagnol mariano rajoy et
carlos que je demande à trois choses
importantes n'appelle pas dans cette
allocation qui a duré un peu moins d'une
dizaine de minutes à l'indépendance il
laisse en clair le déclenchement de à
madrid le soin d'eux des clashs et
l'article 155 qui est la mise sous
tutelle de la catalogne
alexis c'est frappant de voir que deux
en fait depuis au moins trois semaines
j'ai plus exactement l'idée c'est
toujours le même scénario qui
intervention après intervention se
reproduit à chaque fois plus de ventes a
le choix entre en gros on arrête ou ont
franchi le pas à chaque fois il hésite
et des rumeurs disent bay va dire que on
qu'il arrête
et là c'était les élections anticipées
puisque les élections anticipées c'était
un moyen de reculer de donner raison à
madrid ou bien il franchit pas de
l'indépendance il proclame
l'indépendance et de la et puis au
dernier moment
il choisit de ne rien dire c'est déjà la
troisième fois que ça se passe cette
conférence de presse nous l'annoncé nous
a dit à 17h30
il va se décider puis on dit non à 13h30
il va annoncer qu'à des élections il y
avait même la date des élections ça
devait être le 21 décembre
et puis finalement il fait un communiqué
pour dire je ne décide rien c'est demain
rajoy qui décideraient on dit c'est très
malin il repousse la balle dans le camp
de rajoy mais rajoy depuis le début à
chaque fois il fait la même chose chaque
fois il franchit un cran de plus et je
moi je pense que demain il va déclencher
l'article 155 et c'est une bonne chose
christophe qu'il déclenche moi je pense
que la solution des élections anticipées
avaient beaucoup davantage parce que
leur mettait la balle au centre c'est à
dire dans la démocratie
mais c'était à mon avis la seule la
seule la seule solution alpha
constitutionnel politiquement claire et
finalement qui arbitrait
de façon la plus normale possible
et j'avoue que j'ai un peu de mal à la
fin j'ai pas de mal à comprendre on voit
très bien pourquoi ce refus de sortir
par le haut pourquoi mais parce qu'ils
sont sûrs de les perdre les élections
cette année aux nantis ce n'est pas le
signe de quelqu'un qui est un fin
politique ou là je rejoins un petit peu
alex élisez moi je vois pas et lautaret
de deux corps il est au milieu de deux
camps il ya des durs qui sont des
gauchistes qui eux sont à fond pour une
peau l'indépendance et il ya sorte de
centre droit indépendantiste parfum qui
attachés aux affaires à l'économie de
caen qui ne veut pas besoin qui a trop
peur de la sortie de rock et opulent
donc il est au milieu de ces deux camps
et à chaque fois que je choisis pas y
avait pas courageux non mais je pense
que le calcul c'est quand même l'article
155 n'empêche pas des élections
simplement c'est madrid qui peut imposer
les élections et il se dit qu'il a plus
de chances de dison de moins les perdre
si elles sont imposés par madrid c'est à
dire que la seule carte qu'il est faux
bien que ce référendum est assez
largement un échec parce que il ya quand
même 60 % des catalans qui n'ont pas dit
oui à l'indépendance qui ne sont pas
allés voter ou thion tous sont allés
voter non comme il ya 80% des catalans
qui soutenait l'idée d'un référendum et
le référendum 90% des personnes ont dit
oui à l'indépendance
je répète peut-être mais il ya 60% des
catalans qui ne sont pas allés voter
pour l'indépendance ce qui est dans un
contexte de confrontation avec le
pouvoir central le signe que l'idée de
l'indépendance est aujourd'hui en
catalogue minoritaires donc par rapport
à ça
la seule carte qui soit bonne pour lui
c'est quand le pouvoir central se durcit
ça a été quand ils ont été trop
répressif
le premier week end et c'est maintenant
si les élections sont des élections
imposé par madrid on pourra dire voilà
c'est ultra nation à votre place et donc
c'est la seule façon de limiter la casse
après un référendum perdu si on voit ça
de loin moi je vous dis au risque de
continuer à avoir votre arithmétique en
objections que fondamentalement c'est un
référendum perdu les référendums gagner
sont sur des questions celle là comme
celle-ci décisifs sont des vraies femmes
à forte participation et fort résultat
assez forts résultats mais très faible
participation
donc une fois qu'on a perdu le
référendum ça devient très difficile de
trouver des sorties de secours qui vous
met fasse pas qui vous déshabille pas
intégralement est donc renvoyé la balle
à chaque fois sur madrid 2 dazont avec
si c'est vrai qu'il le fait à chaque
fois mais on sait ce qu'il peut faire de
moi un mauvais compte tenu de la
faiblesse dans laquelle il se trouve
ça commence à se voir oui carole est ce
que vous rejoignez lax bretons du amelia
non mais je pense que voilà c'est le
problème pour lui c'est que ça commence
à se voir
c'est à dire qu'on voit bien qu'ils
renvoient la patate chaude si je veux
dire à madrid parce qu'effectivement il
est coincé donc on fond il décide de ne
pas décider
et c'est jamais une bonne chose et le
risque qu'ils courent en laissant madrid
décidé chaque fois c'est d'avoir l'air
d'être un homme qui ne prend pas
offenser responsable juste un mot quand
même formation c'est une non décision
qui penche d'un côté puisque l'autre
c'est à dire qu'il ya quand même eu un
référendum dont il nous a dit le soir
même que c'était une décision claire
pour l'indépendance et l'indépendance
une 16 de palabres au crâne et donc en
vérité c'est une marche a juste une
dernière question
carole pour faire transition avec eux ce
qu'on va aborder ensuite c'est quand
même pas plus excitant ce qui se passe
en espagne par rapport à ce qui se passe
en france dans cette espèce de 2 on sent
qu'il ya quelque chose qui se passe
tandis qu'en france on est dans les
querelles politiques voulaient que la
bretagne et la corse
[Rires]
une présentation encore je ne prends pas
eu ou d'émail avoir la qualité mais
aussi en france que y est conflictuelle
ite maximum au sacré bordel généralisé
juste juste parce que alors juste pour
que les journalistes il a mangé ça c'est
pas une bonne raison
vous avez vous avez voulu bien vous
l'aurez on se plonge dans les délices à
la politique française l'info de l'après
midi ces trois candidats à la présidence
de l air c'est officiel daniel fasquelle
est exclu de la course faute de
parrainages suffisants à linverse de
florence portelli miles de callen et
bien sûr laurent wauquiez alors laurent
wauquiez n'a pas attendu
l'officialisation des instances des
républiques et encore hier soir il était
en campagne à mandelieu la napoule et il
a multiplié les déclarations à tout le
moins forte notamment celles sur les
allocations familiales
on l'écouté je n'accepterai jamais que
l'on vienne contester les droits sociaux
de familles françaises
quand on offre dans le même temps
l'accès à notre sécurité sociale à des
étrangers qui n'ont même jamais cotisé
travail olivier duhamel
c'est la ligne buisson pas très loin oui
pas très loin avec ce raisonnement alors
là pour le coup très bronzée tiens allez
ici ils se brisaient donc qui consiste à
dire 1 il est indispensable pour la
droite de reconquérir un soutien dans
les catégories populaires
2 c'est par la voix d'une et même s'ils
vous pourrez pas ses mots identitaire
qu'on peut convaincre les catégories
populaires
j'ai pas exclu que ce soit pour les
petit pont payant
ça pose quand même quelques problèmes ne
serait ce que sur le maintien d'une
véritable unité de la voix française
parce qu'il ya quand même toute une
partie de la droite qui rejette
absolument cette ligne là alexis brézet
la parole est à la défense
je me défends pas le plus heavy affaire
fait ma position
il a dit que ça pouvait marcher et tant
qu est ce que je peux dire de plus c'est
pas non plus une et ma surprise que
laurent wauquiez qui est candidat à la
présidence du parti de la droite fasse
une campagne à droite
vu ce qu'on veut qu'il fasse d'autre ne
va pas donc il a évidemment pas le choix
allons-nous dit identitaire olivier
d'identitaires dix ans peut-être le
monde le dit c'est une ligne identitaire
pas facile il s'appuie sur les discours
de campagne de laurent wauquiez qui dit
quoi il dit qu' il ya une immigration
incontrôlée que c'est pas bien une
juxtaposition de communautarisme le sel
un film à remplacer l'adoration de la
république ce n'est pas tellement
identitaire de dire ça va tous les
dessous de macron le salafisme
remplaçait est dit il ne faut pas que
nous allions vers une juxtaposition de
communautés ou le service m'a remplacé
l'agression de la république française
accuse macro et les nomades rognant sur
cette ligne
d'après les extraits qui sont dans le
monde je crois pas il dit je préfère ce
vieux pays émouvant aux tristes village
global
c'est de la rhétorique classique de la
droite tous les candidats de droite en
10 ans
la résidence est arrêté mais alors qui
va dire dans ce pays qui préfèrent le
salafisme à l'adoration de l'année
kinshasa il dit pas que quelques clics
on préfère le salafisme et dit
qu'aujourd'hui dans un centre de
quartier le salafisme est en train de
prendre la place de la république
c'est un enfant tout le monde le sait
les n'y a pas que la droite n'y a pas
que delannoy qui dès sa mine va se dit
la même chose à ce qu'il n'y a pas que
vous et lui qui préfère la république
française il faut bien sûr que de bien
sûr que deux pénalités aux clients
l'attendent héros à gaza quand on
regarde son programme alors ce programme
c'est formidable il est pour des quotas
d'immigration la restauration des peines
planchers la suppression d'un médicale
d'état
ces mots pour mots le programme d'alain
juppé tous les mesures de son programme
c'est celui d'alain juppé mais qu'à la
jupe et on dit c'est un centriste et les
nouveaux quais ont 17 ans identitaire
mais si on regarde le contenu de ces
mesures c'est la même chose ça il ya
aussi des choses pour quelqu'un comme
moi sont totalement scandaleuse parce
que c'est la négation même de ce que
j'ai fait pendant 40 ans de ma vie quand
il explique que la caste trop grave
technocratique enseigne à nos jeunes que
la droite c'est le mal géré moi j'ai
enseigné pendant le buzz est tard
catherine rich notre université
c'est pas du dossier si vous avez tort
de vous garer
jamais en ses idées à la droite c'est
mal ni de près ni de loin
ça vous choque dans l'université
française on n'est jamais enseigné sa
femme universitaire l'université
française avec un grand q on n'a jamais
enseigné ça il ya un fait il ya des gens
qui ont pu enseigner ça l'université
française dans son ensemble n'a pas
jamais ensuite la droite c'est mal la
parole est un spécialiste de l'éducation
carol bartz est assez logique question
c'est assez logique que laurent wauquiez
sasso campagne sur ce thème la note
d'abord c'est tout ce qui lui reste mme
ardon mais nous devons quand même le
préciser parce que emmanuel macron fait
quand même sur le plan économique
pas mal de réforme qu'attendent et la
droite donc il reste alors invoqué
effectivement tout un certain nombre de
thèmes anti élites
parce que c'est là dessus qu'il fait
campagne ces anti élites effectivement
ça peut lui apporter les voix des
électeurs des catégories populaires ce
qu'il recherche parce que la droite un
problème de ce côté là c'est clair donc
on fonce et pas c'est pas c'est pas très
étonnant la question c'est quand même
excusez moi bien sûr
non mais on est d'accord mais là on
parle et je d'efficacité électoral
potentiel bon après il peut être qu'il
faut qu'il fasse attention à emmanuel
macron laurent alors est-ce que juste
avant mais juste je vais demander qu'un
mât christophe de voeux qui est un
spécialiste de rhétorique politique
c'est bien joué on parle plus dé
constructif
quand on parle justement de cinq mois je
crois que finalement tout le monde est
malgré tout assez d'accord il est assez
logique
il est assez logique sur le marché
politique chinoise et olivier oui ils
sont même pas d'accord
il aime assez normal que la droite se
positionne sur des valeurs de droite
encore une fois il est historiquement
parlant je suis désolé mais l'identité
nationale le travail
les allocations familiales universelles
ce sont des valeurs il va pas relever
d'ailleurs cette info du figaro que pas
mal d'allocs ont pu profiter d'ailleurs
à des gens qui sont partis faire le
djihad c'est une information
donc il arrive donc au revoir il ya une
place à prendre puisque qu'est ce que
chamakh romat rompre quand même monde
mais je peux me tromper un énorme espace
on est d'accord macro prend un énorme
espace sauf la question identitaire sur
laquelle seul en excédant les grands
cris récemment par olivier duhamel
il est très contradictoire il ya
évidemment une place à prendre
il l'apprend je dire eh bien justement
on va l'écouter quand il parle de
maquereaux et on va se demander s'il a
pas trouvé une façon de s'opposer au
président de la république
c'était juste après d'ailleurs que la
salle épuisé d'après mario world la
france ont les coûts
la france n'est pas un territoire ouvert
à tous les vents financiers et
migratoire la france c'est d'abord une
terre lui qui explique qu'il n'ya pas de
culture française comme il l'a fait à
lyon capitale des gaules je ne sens pas
chez lui cet amour de la france
je ne sens pas chez lui cette empathie
quand il va vers les autres carole
barjon il tout juste ou pas alors
c'était juste pendant la campagne
effectivement parce que je pense que
tout le monde rame marqué que la
campagne emmanuel macron il l'a fait
beaucoup quand même en s'appuyant sur un
électorat plutôt à gauche en revanche
depuis qu'il est au pouvoir il fait
plutôt une politique pour la droite mais
c'est vrai que ce qui manquait dans la
campagne de maquereaux et enfin en tout
cas c'est plus exactement ce dont ils ne
parlaient pas s'était effectivement de
l'identité française il attrape pas
pratiquement pas parlé d'immigration et
c est bien entendu que la laurent
wauquiez s'est dit il ya un créneau sauf
que sauf qu'il aurait peut-être laurent
wauquiez aurait peut-être dû lire le
discours sur l'insécurité des manuels
m'apprend la semaine dernière que manuel
valls a très bien lui lui et nous pardon
de parler un peu de ce journal mais nous
publions cette semaine une interview de
manuel valls ou lui il relève que
emmanuel macron parle désormais ce qui
est tout à fait nouveau de défis
d'ordre civilisationnel dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme
et vous savez que ça c'est quand même
aussi ça fait beaucoup débat entre la
droite et la gauche de savoir si c'était
oui la civilisation occidentale
contre une autre civilisation donc
wauquiez je pense effectivement essai de
s'engouffrer dans ce qui semblait être
une sorte d' angles morts chez makro il
a tort v mais attendons de voir
alors moi quand je lis le livre
d'olivier duhamel et je vois que il
rappelle dans ce livre que notre
emmanuel macron apprécié a été stimulée
par l'histoire mondiale de la france 2
patrick boucheron elle quitte un livre
qui dénonce l'idée d'un roman national
oui enfin c'est c'est très compliqué
d'utilisation qui fait de l'histoire
dans ce type dans leur livre que j'ai
écrit avec laurent bigorgne historien et
alice beaudry écouter pour dire deux
choses je pense qu'il faut distinguer le
fond et puis la nouvelle réalité
politique objective
la vérité politique objectif c'est que
laurent wauquiez va enfin remplir une
place vide qui est celle d'une
opposition à droite à macron va cesser
le tête à tête macro mélenchon qui était
et est réducteur et que c'est une très
bonne chose pour notre démocratie
alors maintenant une fois qu'on a dit ça
et vous allez voir ça va marcher très
bien qui va être très très bien élu dès
le premier tour et qu'ensuite il sera la
figure de l'opposition au moins pendant
des mois et s'il fait bien le job sans
le conduira jusqu'à la candidature à la
présidentielle s'il me fait mal il
passera à autre chose maintenant sur le
fond on peut trouver d'un point de vue
là pour le coup de citoyens que parfois
il pousse quand même le bouchon trop
loin parce que accuser le président de
la république de ne pas aimer la france
c'est quand même une accusation d'une
extrême il coûtait alors je vais
caricaturer un bon tour je vais faire du
wauquiez à l'envers quand j'entends la
france c'est d'abord une terre je ne
sois pas lui cet amour de la france
c'est l'impression thomas p tit liste
par les juges 1941
jonathan fin la taxe oui c'est lui qui
fait déjouer le positif excusez moi
c'est lui qui sait ce qui dit quand il
leur pose là quand il parle de de la
france c'est d'abord une terre il sait
très bien à quoi il fait référence qui
n'est pas complètement idiot et assez
cultivé vous ça vous choque pas que l'on
dise que ma qu'on n'aime pas la france
histoire de maquereaux même en campagne
même dans son rapport à l'histoire dans
sa génération de jeanne da don sur
l'hommage de napoléon dans son
inspiration de bol ça derrière moi mais
je viens d'évoquer pratique la
caricature dans son adversaire pour le
combattre comme c'est le jeu en
politique ça s'appelle de la caricature
alors on le dit après on s'en indigne ou
pas c'est le jeu mais je rejoins carole
de barjots je pense que quand même
quelque chose d'intéressant je pense que
macro à vue ce danger là il a vu ce
danger là il sent bien que c'est une
zone de faiblesse son rapport aux
catégories populaires
le rapport à 7,7 cette population qui se
sentent déranger bousculait malheureuse
à son identité
il l'a vu et qu il commence dans la
rhétorique en tout cas à faire mouvement
vers 7 7 7 cette france là c'est vrai
que ce sont des cours sur l'attention
sur la sécurité partout dans la rue voir
va jusqu'à vouloir rétablir d'ailleurs
contre dans tel qu'il l'a dit au départ
contre la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme la double peine ça
fait qu'ils aient dû pousser pas samedi
n'est pas allé jusqu'à dire qu'il
voulait rétablir la double peine et
d'ailleurs c'était à pas absolument
clair s'il avait dit je veux rétablir la
double peine là on comprenait l'aï dit
il faut et qu'il faut exclure il faut
que ce soit avant même qu'ils étaient
jugés ce qui passe à la double peine
play sont les juges
on les met en prison et a plus rien dire
il a dit aussi si vous l'avez bien de
mettre les chars alexis que tout
étranger en situation irrégulière ayant
commis un délit doit être expressément
sa double peine la doublette c'est tout
étranger en saison régulière
k comme un délit est d'abord juger et
éventuellement emprisonné pour ce délire
et à l'issue de ce délit virer la presse
évidemment aimé berry je sais qu'il faut
qu'il soit jugé
non non on est quand même bien on est
blindé avant les points qu attendait
donc ne me le faites pas semblant de me
conduire je suis en train de dire que ma
croix vu un certain nombre de choses et
qu'effectivement un des dangers mais
c'est aussi peut-être ben ça peut aussi
être un des mérites de deux nouveaux
quais c'est de mettre l'accent sur ces
sujets là et puis après on verra bien
soit macron et c'est après la moitié du
programme de la boîte on économise donc
en l'autre moitié sur la question sur
les questions de sécurité d'identité
d'islam et et à béton là et il sera
vraiment le candidat devrait y aura plus
de place c'est pas évident que ma qu'on
puisse aller où jusque là je crois que
au delà au delà de toutes ces péripéties
et de tous ces discours on va vers une
recomposition politique il faut que tout
le monde est à peu près d'accord là
dessus c'est à dire que macron occupa
très vaste espace est en effet jeu tout
à fait d'accord avec carole barjon il
élargit chaque jour c'est à dire et et
curieusement il élargit surtout à droite
moi je trouve que c'est vraiment ça va
être un cas historiques macron sauté aux
yeux l'homme qui aura escalader
l'everest par la face gauche et qui aura
peut-être régner sur l'everest par la
droite
ça risque d'être ce paradoxe là et avec
quelques dindon de la farce au passage
les autres qui monte whisky les
repousser franchement en mati re de
choquer moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
après je ne suis pas du tout d'accord
avec le diagnostic de de voguer sur
macro mais on va quand même pas se
déclarer choqué dans le combat politique
quand macron lui-même rappelez-vous a
très lourdement rappelé oradour sur
glane pendant la campagne électorale
contre le front national
alors qu'on peut pas dire que marine le
pen tu aimerais vraiment tout seul
christopher bernard david et qui nous
écrit sur sur internet et vous pouvez
continuer à poster vos commentaires
donner vos questions sur la page
facebook du figaro et sur le player du
figaro c'est à dire l'écran dans lequel
voyez cette émission bernard nous écrit
à propos de wauquiez
il va peut-être nous ressortir le coût
du karcher en panne depuis 2007 dix ans
dans l'opposition ça va être long pour
pour laurent wauquiez donc il ya quand
même le romani en dix ans peut-être
[Rires]
en revanche ils essayent de faire plus
sarko que sarko lui-même distincts jeu
de dupes mais qui fait sarko qui se
référent à écouter d'extraordinaire en
ce moment qui se réfère sans arrêt à
nicolas sarkozy ces manuels
il le site il encore citer à saclay hier
il a cité à plusieurs reprises et
toujours en bien alors qu'il dit autre
chose de son prédécesseur il y a quand
même véritablement une une opération
politique une entreprise politique comme
on disait autrefois extraordinaire est
en effet la réactivité là je crois qu'on
sera tous d'accord la réactivité et
l'intelligence politique d' emmanuel
macron est telle qu'en effet le défi
pour laurent wauquiez est considérable
ans après une des questions c'est dans
l'hypothèse où macron ferait aussi dans
ce deuxième secteur du jeu une politique
de droite
aurait-il pour autant les suffrages des
électeurs de droite c'est de même c'est
pas oui évident qu'on peut on peut faire
la politique de ses adversaires qui vous
approuve et puis au moment de vos tenues
ce nombre on va en prendre vraiment
notre camp quand même à tant faire mieux
c'est un risque que macro va devoir
affronter
alors peut-être un autre risque je sais
pas si c'est un autre risque
c'est humain autres thèmes de
l'actualité aujourd'hui puisque l'info
est tombée ce matin c'est à ploërmel
dans le morbihan l'amérique il ya six
mois pas un jour de plus pour enlever la
croix qui surplombe la statue de
jean-paul ii le seul pape à s'être rendu
en bretagne c'était à sainte anne
d'auray en septembre 1996 le conseil
d'état donc assommé la commune d'enlever
cette croix les motifs vous allez les
voir sur l'écran dès lors que la croix
constitue un signe ou emblème religieux
sens de l'article 28 de la loi du 9
décembre 1905 et que son installation
par la commune entre dans un qu'une des
exceptions ménagé par cet article sa
présence dans un emplacement public est
contraire à la loi alexis c'est
imparable ça
en face il faut enlever toutes les croix
dans l'espace public d'ailleurs du
boulot certains vendredi
s'il n'y a pas une russe il n'y a pas
une route dans un calvaire et c'est
quand même encore le conseil d'état que
je vais pas forcément défendre érigé par
la commune avec l'aide de la corée
c'est pas tout les croire en soi terry
c'est pas comme si on perd de bonne foi
c'est très bien d'avoir ces publics dans
l'aï dit qu'on n'a pas le droit d'élever
ou d'apposer aucun signe ou emblème sur
les bancs publics ou deux sur quelques
emplacements publics
bon il ya beaucoup de croissance voit
son public par ailleurs alors là vous
allez peut-être voir une incongruité
danser sur la loi est la loi dit al il
est interdit à l'avenir pour le passager
lui l'arrêt du match à la mi mai par
ailleurs la première laisse alors la
circulation aulas jean paul 2 mais ça
tout cas moi je ne comprends pas
beaucoup de gens savent que c'est pas
bien sûr c'est là où on peut dire qu'à
part parce que bon ça paraît évident que
compte tenu de la loi de séparation de
l'église et de l'état partir du moment
où c'est une commune une mairie qui a
voulu ériger cette chronique on lui
demande de l'enlever ça paraît assez
logique mais dans ce cas la cohérence eu
peut-être voulu que pour pourquoi une
statue du pape
pourquoi est-ce qu'une mairie qui est
l'émanation effectivement des citoyens
de la république
c'est un double un don d'un artiste à
temps c'est un don d'un artiste c'est
vrai faisait d'ailleurs carole barjon je
suis en désaccord avec vous et hélas
hélas hélas en accord avec alexis brézet
bien que ne bénéficiant pas d'une fois
on dira temps celui attribué à saint
jean de verges
je trouve que venir emmerder les gens
sur le fait qu'on vit une statue de
jean-paul ii ou pas ici une croix ou pas
c'est un sétois jean pull bleu et à des
personnages de l'histoire du monde
jean paul ii nous ait dépassé quasiment
jamais sans sa croix maître jean paul ii
sont s'accroît c'est totalement absurde
et que franchement le conseil d'état
pourrait faire preuve d'un peu moins de
juridisme et d'un peu plus de
compréhension mais mais mais à ce moment
là si alexis brézet est d'accord pour
une interprétation tolérante de la loi
de 1905
elle doit être tolérante pour tous y
compris par exemple quand pour éviter
des prières de rue on trouve des voix
d'associations culturelles et autres
pour aider ou
des bail emphytéotique ou que sais-je
encore pour aider à la construction de
mosquées
si on veut on peut pas et tolérant dans
l'interprétation de la loi de 1905 pour
les catholiques et rigide pour les
musulmans oullins vernon mais consciente
mosquée personnes dès lors que c'est
légal et qui a pas de fonds publics dans
la course une mosquée n'y a pas de
problème financier lieux de culte
jusqu'à présent on n'a pas droit à des
fonds plus c'est d'ailleurs absolument
tourner pour laquelle la question des
champions c'est bien ce que l'on élit
alors ce soit diane 2 il ya deux
éléments se voyant en tolérant pour nous
parce que je vois sur la notion même le
sourire la joie oui oui bah oui à ben
arous de la jurisprudence du conseil
d'état qui vous répétez ce qui s'appuie
sur wii sur la question des traditions
locales
c'est un élément constant de l'attelage
de jeu selon le conseil d'état
premièrement et deuxièmement de l'ordre
public le conseil d'état dit léon faut
pas faire des trucs qui font de l'ordre
d'être où l'on veut dire est ce que les
croix sont dans la tradition de la
bretagne
j'aurais tendance à dire oui bon est ce
que cette croquerait les créateurs un
trouble en au public en bretagne
j'aurais tendance à dire non donc c'est
un parcours arguments juridiques que je
ne suis pas d'accord avec vous chez
relation mais le fait d'être intolérant
ci s'installe une tradition de présence
musulmane forte
j'aurais tendance à dire oui est-ce que
les traditions locales doivent
s'interpréter pas seulement de celle que
vous vénérez du 19e siècle catholicisme
mais au fur et à mesure qu'elles peuvent
se modifier et évoluer j'aurais tendance
à dire nous agissions faut laisser le
temps la tradition de s'installer voilà
nous verrons bien mais bon la vie
d'antan qui considérait que d'édifier
une mosquée sur fonds publics soit dans
les traditions de ce pays et c'est à
dire non seulement peut pas donner ça
les salles de grier oui dès lors qu'il
ya des gens pour les financer car
évidemment déroulement je tenais juste à
préciser que je vois là je ne faut pas
faire une fausse interprétation ce que
j'ai dit j'ai parlé de la cohérence qui
auraient éventuellement mener à mais je
ne suis pas du tout pour qu'on fasse
enlever la statue de jean-paul ii le
contrat ne rêve pas d'un statut reste
dans mes sculptures aussi le conseil
d'état est fréquent même qui est un peu
plus de sécurité juridique et stabilité
juridique de ce pays dans cette affaire
le tribunal administratif a interdit
tout le monument ensuite la cour
administrative d'appel a annulé la
décision du tribunal administratif
et enfin le conseil d'état prend tout le
monument sauf la croix plus que c'était
droit trop de l'excellent de droit le
conseil d'état est plus gilles ans que
sur la taxe sur les dividendes sur du
temps passe sur beaucoup hélas oui mais
est ce qu'il est il pour être enfin je
sais pas mais on parle d'oeuvres d'art
ya une oeuvre d'art qui a fait couler
beaucoup d'encre qui arrive en bout et
qui étonnant qu'une forme masculine qui
fait subir les derniers outrages à une
forme donc n'hésitez pas une femme c'est
un animal au mythe forme servir sexe il
prend par derrière mais bien le truc
c'est à monsieur et remparts derrière on
le dit mais c'est pas une dame
c'est un animal est donc la spa a porté
plainte c'est vrai est donc très
attention dont on est dans un pays on a
le droit de mettre sa cette statue la
quiétude awada sur libé sera pas
publique on dit faut enlever la croix au
dessus de jean paul ii pardon khordad
cette croix en fait bien ça date d'il ya
une dizaine d'années il me semble c'est
est un don qui a été fait à la mairie de
ploërmel par les n'oublions jamais que
le conseil d'état le reconnaît lui-même
quand il parle de sa propre approche
casuistique un artiste russe merci
charles darche qui nous qui me corrige
et merci au conseil d'état de nous faire
perdre du temps à parler d'eux c'est pas
parce que j'ai quand même le sujet le
plus important pour l'avenir et la
question subsidiaire
question subsidiaire olivier le maire de
ploërmel lui a réagi la statue fait
partie depuis 12 ans du paysage de
ploërmel ça ne dérange nullement les
habitants c'est au contraire un atout
touristique indéniable pour la commune
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré à l'afp
et donc c'est un atout touristique
indéniable pour la commune le maire de
ploërmel envisage de saisir la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
s'amusait selon vous pour comparaison il
a gagné au contraire c'est très bien il
va gagner que la fédération de la libre
pensée
je crois que c'est elle également qui
avaient commandé demandé l'interdiction
des crèches
oui de noël et ose espérer que si la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
donne tant conseil d'état etc alexis
approuvé applaudissent et bien la même
cour européenne si elle me
si elle vient jamais la céda même si
elle donne tort à la double peine
stricte et au fait que par exemple à
l'étranger qui a commis un délit
relativement pas grave en plus vit en
france depuis 15 ans et marié en france
à des enfants qui sont nés en france les
qui ont 12 13 ans et qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas expulser le père un coup
grâce à ou à cause de direction de
l'accord open il faudra à ce moment-là
qu'il approuve aussi il peut pas prouver
que quand ça l'arrangé
c'est comme quand vous anticipez une
décision de la cour européenne
après quand on croit décision que
j'approche du bon bah ça n'est sûrement
pas mais vous sert la politique c'est à
suivre mais je suis certain que la cour
européenne va donner raison à la mairie
de plus c'est un moyen de fond des
racines chrétiennes
ah non alors la cour européenne elle est
extrêmement libérale au sens anglo saxon
du terme mais elle va dire liberté
religieuse d'abord deux tweets pour
alimenter le débat
d'abord 7,7 sweet sur l'un cimetière
américain qui montre bien tout les crois
qu'il y a sur ces cimetières la statue
de jean paul ii va se voir retirer sa
croix le conseil d'état risque d'avoir
un peu de travail s'il continue à ce
rythme là c'était pour donner raison
avec six blessés enfin je suis
respectueux de la hiérarchie tt
colleville c'est un territoire américain
non mais vous en avez également ils
n'auraient rien c'est seulement c'est
une enclave c'est très serré et olivier
meneghel qui dit également sur twitter
la justice ordonne le retrait de la
croix surplombant la statue de jean-paul
ii et qui montre justement une prod
signalisation avec la question j'enlève
celle là aussi bon voilà ce que pour
mettre un petit peu de liant parce que
cela le dire est que le prochain thème
est un petit peu plus lourd je vous le
promets c'est pas une blague même de
mauvais goût vous allez voir la fiche
qu'on peut lire sur un camion qu'on
pouvait lire en tous les cas dans le
quartier latin ces dernières heures
on va la voir dans un instant c'est pas
écrit en écriture inclusive mais seuil
étudiants et les étudiantes romantique
passion et pas de prêt étudiant sortait
avec un chauffeur dé dit je suis garé ma
marine sugar mama
le site s'appelle riche mythe beautiful
également le la riche rencontre le la
magnifique
en clair il s'agit de mettre en relation
et je mets des guillemets en d2 view de
vieilles riche avec des étudiants ou des
étudiantes fauché en pleine campagne
balances ton port qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire le plus grand dégoût et et on se
demande même comment comment c'est
possible
voilà comment est ce possible d'abord
d'avoir cette cette idée là oui sûrement
mais enfin c'est du proxénétisme même
pas déguiser et voilà il revient se
balader dans les rues devant les facs
oui c'est absolument de la prostitution
enfin je comprends même pas comment ça
peut arriver aujourd'hui parce que
attendez vous
quand même lire lire ce que dit ce site
un retrouver la jeunesse grâce à la
présence d'une jeune femme pétillante
vous vous sentirez dix ans plus jeune
est revigoré avec une showgirl baby
ardente à vos côtés bon bah voilà qui
est clair
il ya la musique prothèse pour
l'expliquer ce poids des gens qui
animent ce site ont l'esprit beaucoup
beaucoup plus déréglé que le conseil
d'état qu'il a déjà un peu lorsqu'il
prend la décision qu'il a prise sur
ploërmel
soit ce sont des grands finaux qui se
disent bon d'accord je vais me faire
taper dessus mais je vais avoir une pub
d'enfer
tout le monde va découvrir mon site et
grâce à ça je vais faire des affaires
c'est le moulin et je peux pas vous dire
laquelle des hypothèses alors juste les
lois en france des devises l'incitation
à la débauche
il ya des lois sur la protection des
mineurs doit surtout avec la wii mais
enfin aller faire le con renvoya pas un
policier qui plutôt que mettre des pv
apparaît tel alexis vous avez la réponse
dans le figaro étudiant au fort de l'or
on apprend que des plaintes ont été déjà
été déposées dès 2014 la justice alors
avait classé la plainte sans suite
notamment d'une association qui lutte
contre le proxénétisme une association
de magistrats qui s'appelle équipes
d'action contre le proxénétisme est le
motif avancé ces essais site ne propose
pas de la prostitution mais de l'escort
c'est en tout cas ce qu'explique le
responsable de cette association de
magistrats il y avait porté plainte
qu'est ce qu'une autre choc près de
temps cette émission vise pratique ici à
autre chose étonnante dans cette affaire
jouent ce jeu là mais j'assume est votre
réflexion c'est la réponse ce matin de
marlène schiappa à nos confrères de sud
radio justement sur cette question sur 7
entre guillemets subtilité on écoute
c'est pas un bus de prostitution et
c'est là qu'est la subtilité c'est que
c'est présenté comme un but de sites de
rencontres entre jeunes et personnes
âgées et riche faire personnes plus
âgées et riche effectivement ces
problèmes à 6 qu'il faut qu'on regarde
c'est est ce qu'il s'agit de rencontres
ressenti ou est-ce qu'il s'agit
effectivement de proxénétisme et d'une
forme d'incitation à la prostitution ce
qui là pour être mais effectivement sous
le coup de la loi donc on est en train
de regarder très précisément les aspects
juridiques de jeu comprend pas très bien
parce qu'il ya quand même l'adjectif
riche partir du moment où ils adjectif
riches
on parle bien d'argent à un moment donné
donc donc je comprends pas bien
à redon site qui touche sa part le site
qui tous à part c'est le maquereau le
riche c'est la [ __ ] dans le riche ses
clients et la l'étudiant que c'est la
[ __ ]
soyons clair donc c'est vrai ils sont
couverts d'hématomes soit je suis dans
ma blessure mais ça marche dans tous les
sens reims ont bien assumé donc
évidemment que c'est dur proxénétisme
qu'est ce que c'est d'autres c'est dire
si vous voulez vous faire de l'argent
passait par le site ça c'est un agronome
à prendre sa part et vous allez pouvoir
avoir un délire des actions en justice
mais sur la base de sa le procureur
devrait dire vous les arrêter vous
fermez vous voyez bardintzeff bien ça
nous avait habitués à être un peu parce
que je suis me disait qu'elle gagne pas
plus fort je comprends pas mais roanne
vous nous avez rejoint vous êtes au
service réseaux sociaux le figaro.fr
alors pourquoi on parle de cette affaire
que c'est très commentée c'est très
agitée dans les réseaux sociaux depuis
ce matin c'est l'un des sujets les plus
commentés sur twitter est en fait ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que ce site est
arrivé récemment en france et dans une
trentaine d'autres pays c'est un site
scandinaves et s'est littéralement le
meilleur coup de pub qu'il ait pu avoir
en fait parmi parmi les sujets du moment
alors moi j'ai été voir le site internet
en question derrière cette publicité et
je me suis créé un profil pour voir à
quoi ressemblait cette étrange site dont
on parle est la description est plutôt
étonnante moi je me suis pas inscrit
pour les trois personnels et en plus
avec ma brigands je me suis définit
comme un sugar baby donc c'est moi qui
ai besoin d'argent et ont défini les
personnes sugar babies comme des
personnes qui n'ont pas peur de définir
exactement ce qu'ils attendent de leurs
partenaires sur le coup je me suis dit
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent dire je suis
allé un peu plus loin j'ai rempli mon
profil comme d'autres sites de
rencontres traditionnelles et en fait
après avoir décrit mes caractéristiques
physiques on me demande mon style de vie
comprenez prétentions salariales
ça va de 5000 euros à peu près par mois
à plus de 10000 euros je sais pas quelle
école de commerce demande plus de 10000
euros par mois mais bon donc sur le site
on n'y trouve pas mal de jeunes
d'ailleurs c'est la plupart des profils
que j'ai pu constater des jeunes qui ont
besoin d'argent en france ou ailleurs et
on a déjà une pétition sur internet qui
a été lancé et qui recueille plus de
2600 signatures pour fermer ce site et
j'ai demandé à nos internautes via le
compte twitter du figaro étudiant ce
qu'ils en pensaient et à notre question
ils ont étaient 57% à être choqué de
cette publicité devant l'université
paris descartes
parmi nos internautes on a notamment mal
vu qui nous dit ce canon une provocation
que je considère cependant comme
positive
il attire l'opinion sur des faits
terribles qui existe depuis longtemps
pour arrondir les fins de mois de
certains étudiants dans le besoin
on a géré ni coton aussi qui nous dit
marlène schiappa et faussement perplexes
ou interrogative si réellement il
s'agissait d'un mécénat de la part de
vieux monsieur riche subventionnant de
manière désintéressée de jeunes
étudiantes
pourquoi ne pas passer directement à la
fac mais les tweets les plus relayée sur
twitter
hormis des articles de presse ce sont
des personnalités des médias ou des
journalistes eux mêmes qui dénoncent le
fait d'en parler
on a notamment fabrice pelosi qui nous
dit bravo héros de twitter qui ont
dénoncé
on sait la pub ça a fait l'ouverture du
journal de la matinale de france inter
on à edouard de maréchal journaliste au
figaro qui dénonçait un tweet de nicolas
poincaré qui nous dit européen dénonce
ce matin le site sugar daddy qui du coup
daddy pardon qui du coup vient faire sa
pub sous les fenêtres de la radio notre
journaliste ne répond pub qui du coup
est gracieusement relayé par vos centres
sur les réseaux sociaux avec hacker le
tweet y répond et par vous du coup on
n'en finit plus fort et en bon
journaliste
je l'assumé mais on a le contemple un
nageur du figaro étudiant qui a pu
repérer quelque chose d'assez dramatique
c'est que le site en question qui s'en
sert tranquillement dans cluster google
news alors que le google news c'est la
partie de google qui référence les
articles de presse du jour on pouvait
pas rêver meilleure pub et c'est
peut-être ce que l'on continue à faire
en ce momen alors comment dénoncer
quelque chose sans en faire la promotion
indirectement vous avez quatre heures a
beaucoup apporté comme il ya une
troisième hypothèse christophe degruelle
ou qui est un spécialiste
quand même pas la question n'a pas de la
caisse non je demanderai pas si c'est la
version moderne du viewer bons qu'ils
recherchent les oies blanches mais
est-ce que c'est pas un stade d'une
question provocatrice est ce que c'est
pas un stade ultime du libéralisme et
qui est en particulier du libéralisme
venus d'europe du nord ou bien de qui
qui s'illustrent qui s'illustrent là
c'est ce que par exemple aux pays bas
dans le sens d'un certain nombre de ces
pays de ce système est tout à fait
tolérer l'intolérance accepté en effet
sous le nom d' escort et puis il ya
plein de choses qui peuvent
éventuellement se mettre derrière mais
j'aime pas le mot libéralisme pour cela
je parlerais plutôt de marchandisation
c'est à dire que ce que un petit peu ce
que disait olivier duhamel c'est l'idée
du richesse c'est ce que carole la
marchandisation des corps en
l'occurrence il s'agit bien de ça c'est
à dire les changes
de son corps contre une rémunération et
ça c'est quelque chose qui marque qui me
paraît beaucoup plus de mots qui me
paraît beaucoup plus approprié que le
mot libéralisme
parce que le libéralisme vous pouvez
dire tout adam smith pouvait lire tout
jeune rôle se trouverait jamais un
encouragement à ce genre de pratique
juste une dernière précision on trouve
en suisse à genève
ou bien aux pays-bas de la prostitution
quasiment légaliser c'est pour ça que je
pose la question
oui mais alors là après rendant un sujet
plus vaste parce que le point sur lequel
on peut s'accorder
c'est le terme qui a été utilisé un
produit par carole barjon c'est
proxénétisme
ce site est un site proxénète voilà
après la prostitution lips est un autre
sujet et à nos débats pas le lancer
maintenant
bon on ne relancera une prochaine fois
merci beaucoup mais roanne il y à un
autre débat qui est dans la halle
étrangers c'est celui qui concerne la
les conditions réelles de la mort de
john kennedy ça fait un certain nombre
d'années sinon décennies que ça dure
3100 dossiers sont donc livrés au public
en tous les cas c'est ce qu'on attend
c'est la promesse de donald trump
le président américain a demandé la
déclassification des archives de la cia
sur la mort de jfk sept en tout cas en
ces termes qu'il a présenté les choses
sur twitter il y a cinq jours traduction
libre en tant que président j'autorise
l'ouverture des dossiers kennelly
bloqués et classifié christophe de voogd
trump champion de la transparence
là j'ai lu tout et son contraire sur ce
sujet j'ai l'impression que en fait
cette ouverture et dossier était prévu
de longue date avait été annoncée et des
années par les autorités judiciaires
maintenant je certains disent que c'est
rome qui prend qui prend la décision là
j'avoue que mon ignorance et est presque
totale d'autant que les dossiers en
question font 200 mille pages et j'ai
pas eu le temps de les lire juste avant
l'émission
donc je vous confie l'excellent dossier
dans le figaro ce matin où il ya quand
même pas mal de papa formation justement
qui donne pas encore d'informations mais
olivier c'est quand même bien joué de la
part de trump quelqu'un qui
accusé d'avoir été un brin sûr effective
c'est bien joué sauf si ce qui vient
nous est dit est vrai et qu'on apprend
dans les gens qui viennent qu'il a rien
autorisée du tout puisque c'était
autorisé de longue date avec jump il
faut se méfier donc en effet si si il y
avait toujours un vrai blocage et
citroën a passé outre et a donné cette
autorisation
là tout d'un coup lui qui a mis
tellement insulter les médias
souhaitaient la presse insulter les
enquêtes insulter tout ce qu'on veut il
apparaîtra comme surtout dans la logique
américaine et dans l'esprit américain où
la transparence est absolument
indispensable
le champion de la vérité en tout cas ça
me paraît avoir une vertu pour trump
c'est d'alimenter un des ressorts de son
élection c'est le compléter enfin on
vous cache on vous a caché la vérité
donc en disant je vais vous dévoiler des
choses il l'entretient ce mousseux cet
état d'esprit là peut-être à juste titre
dans ce dossier là je n'en sais
absolument rien mais donc déjà ça en
tout cas ça entre avec cohérence avec la
promesse implicite qui fait assez à ses
électeurs je suis celui qui vous dit la
vérité alors que les autres vous la
cache
et voyez moi je vais vous la mettre sur
la table par ailleurs il met la doit
aussi peut-être pour qu'ils reposent
essentiellement sur les turpitudes des
démocrates
déjà la sphère weinstein c'était déjà le
les voyelles et des mousses et
démocrates qui donne des leçons regardez
comme ils sont et là ça va être en tous
cas on va mettre commencé à tournicoter
dans des affaires kennedy et ça lui
permet de se mettre à distance de tout
ça carole c'est une belle façon de
montrer qui est pas contre le fait news
qu'il n'est pas utile et c'est lui c'est
une bonne façon de montrer de la part de
30 kg contre l'effet que news ou pas en
sortir et qui les nourrissent a pas
convaincu
[Rires]
je suis pas du tout sûr qu'il sera
contrôlé cette news donc et je suis pas
sûr qu'il ait envie de montrer qu'ils
les deux bouts je crois en plus un débat
beaucoup plus vaste et il n'a pas non
plus le monopole historique ni politique
d'aidé fake news même si l'ennui plus
plus que les autres cas s'ils peuvent
faire là vous aimerez pierre
l'establishment leur a menti c'est à une
victoire politique incroyable il a bien
dit vous avez tout à fait raison il dit
en fait dans cette affaire j'agis comme
american la zone américaine et c'est un
autre c'est à dire quelqu'un qui ne ment
pas vale en termes d'administration
d'établissements
est-ce que ça justement ne l'avantagent
pas dans son bras de fer contre une
autre institution avec laquelle il a
quand même pas mal de problèmes c'est la
cia alors là c'est là on entre dans les
arcanes du pouvoir demander trop je
pense que la seule chose qui intéresse
enfin jusqu'à présent d'après ce qu'on
dit dans les archives de kennedy c'est
quand même semblerait une articulation
beaucoup plus forte qu'on le pensait
entre oswald et les services secrets
soviétiques et cubain alors et ça ça ça
peut être très astucieux notamment dans
un un billard à trois bandes avec la
russie voyez ce que je veux dire les
démocrates et les compromissions
éventuelle du passé est-ce qu'on aurait
laissé faire est ce que la cia aurait
laissé faire c'est quelque chose qui à
l'air en tout cas d'après ce que j'ai pu
dire encore une fois mais dans les
parce que ces documents sont été publié
deux heures avant avant notre mission si
cette piste qui moi me paraît d'ailleurs
historiquement assez solides d'un
téléguidage plus puissants compenser
d'oswald par les services de l'est et de
cuba à ce moment là on aurait quelque
chose d'intéressant politiquement pour
trump avec sid
j'ai rien à rajouter sur cet important
sujet bien eh ben je vous rappelle le
dernier
l'info de l'après midi donc c'est
l'annoncent par carlos car l'espèce
demande la même annonce plus exactement
des trials il n'y aura pas d'élection
une double bande annonce il n'y aura pas
d'élection il n'ya pas il ne convoque
pas d'élections anticipées en catalogne
et ils n'appellent pas à l'indépendance
c'est ce qu'il a déclaré juste avant le
début de cette émission vous restez avec
nous
dans un enfant dans un instant focus sur
ce que bruno le maire a appelé un
scandale d'état des milliards d'euros
perdus avec une taxe mal fagotée comment
en es tu arrives
comment en est on arrivé là et bien
guillaume richard répond aux questions
d'ariane le coeur à très vite sur figure
au live
[Musique]